Bienvenidos a la entrevista de France 24
Hoy estamos con Mario cubi y él es
viceministro de gobierno del gabinete de
Guillermo lasso en Ecuador Un gobierno
que tiene ahora mismo funciones
limitadas bajo tutela de la corte
constitucional luego de que el propio
laso declarara la muerte Cruzada en el
marco del juicio político en su contra
por presunto delito de peculado señor
cuy muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros hoy en 24 Gracias a ustedes por
el espacio siempre gusto conversar Bueno
lo primero que le quiero preguntar es
cómo se ha vivido todo este proceso del
juicio político de la muerte Cruzada
dentro del gobierno Mira no fue una
decisión sencilla fue un proceso
realmente y tampoco es algo de uno o dos
semanas que es donde se concreta esto
viene de un ejercicio de casi dos años
donde una oposición que no ha tenido los
intereses de la población de los
intereses que promulgaron durante una
campaña en mente sino simplemente la
intención de sacar al presidente del
como sea para ellos tomarlo y esto se
demuestra en cuatro intentos de
derrocamiento al presidente en menos de
dos años el último este maladado juicio
político que empezó con una supuesta
investigación en enero 2023 donde
inicialmente querían acusar al
presidente y lo dijeron públicamente te
traición a la patria cuando se dieron
cuenta que no tenía ni pies ni cabeza
Porque además requiere de elementos
bélicos migraron a inventarse una figura
que se llamaba peculado por omisión es
decir que había abusado de fondos
públicos sin abusar de fondos públicos
en esa línea pasamos casi cuatro meses
los Ecuatorianos donde la asamblea no
aprobaba leyes no se dedicaba su tarea
de entregar las herramientas necesarias
a través de normativas sino simplemente
de atacar visceralmente al gobierno
nacional el presidente de la República
en esa línea digamos durante las últimas
semanas incluyendo cuando el presidente
lasso fue a la asamblea nacional o al
congreso equivalente en Ecuador a
presentar su defensa Dentro de este
proceso también se identificó con
claridad que los asambleístas no les
importaba la verdad el derecho los
derechos
terminaron incluso una ex asambleísta
valga la redundancia valga decirlo
acusando de asesinato abiertamente el
presidente con eso me parece que el
presidente con Claridad identificó que
no había la voluntad ni la intención de
hacer un trabajo responsable desde
legislativo para que el ejecutivo pueda
responder a la ciudadanía y que dos años
más de este bloqueo incesante y racional
no le hacía bien al país entonces en una
decisión que es compleja porque para
decirlo con Claridad esto también
provoca esa disolución de la asamblea
nacional que el presidente corte
superior presidencial para el que le
quedaban dos años de virtud para lo que
fue electo en seis o siete meses que
culminará la si es que hay una segunda
vuelta en las elecciones anticipadas que
se han convocado pero su decisión es en
virtud del país es decir dos años más de
este ataque del legislativo no le hace
bien a los Ecuatorianos desde ahí esta
puerta que al final se convierte en una
nueva oportunidad para el Ecuador para
que sean los ciudadanos a través de su
voto en las urnas en democracia quienes
digan cómo quieren que esto avance Yo
quiero preguntarles cuando conocieron
ustedes la decisión del presidente
porque en alguna entrevista ha dicho que
fue a defenderse Sabiendo ya que podría
tener que podría declarar la muerte de
Cruzada cuando lo supieron ustedes
dentro del gabinete Bueno mira la muerte
Cruzada como tal que el concepto
constitucional es disolución de la
asamblea y convocatoria de elecciones
anticipadas a estado sobre la mesa hace
meses meses Incluso en su momento en
junio del 2022 el presidente contempló
utilizarla en una crisis decidió no
hacerlo en ese momento y seguir
intentando llegar a acuerdos básicos en
virtud de la Democracia con la asamblea
Así que te diría que la decisión
definitiva así decirte ya lo sabemos
hasta que el presidente lo firmó entre
la noche del martes la mañana del
miércoles sin embargo es cierto como lo
había anunciado el secretario jurídico
de Presidencia que el decreto estaba
preparado Porque la idea es herramienta
en el caso del presidente así lo decía
es decir decirte ya estaba lista desde
antes no ya estaba listo el hecho que
podía hacer una alternativa y me parece
que ese ejercicio de defensa en la
asamblea fue clave no Porque sea parte
del juicio sino porque evidenció que no
importa que se le presentara a los ex
asambleístas querían simplemente la
cabeza el presidente aún con
declaraciones te digo Tan terribles y no
lo digo como viceministro sino como
Ciudadano del Ecuador como abiertamente
en el parlamento acusar de asesinato
presidente de la república sin ningún
miramento Quiero hablarle ahora de un
hecho crucial en todo en todo este
proceso y es que una vez que el
presidente declara la muerte Cruzada
tempranamente las fuerzas militares
declaran el apoyo a este movimiento
había habido ya conversaciones previas
para que los dos movimientos fueran de
la mano en el caso de que hubiera
protestas en las calles Mira desde hace
mucho y como es parte natural del
ejercicio del poder se coordinan cuando
pueden existir eventos como ya hubo
lastimosamente en junio 2022 con fuerza
armadas con policía pero son operativos
de ordinarios de seguridad es decir es
verificar qué alertas existen en
territorio qué potencialidades existen
de levantamientos para mantener la paz y
el orden público en ese sentido Me
parece que lo que pasó con Fuerza Armada
y policías fue un adelanto de ellos a
decir miren esto es una herramienta
constitucional esperamos en ese momento
todavía que la corte constitucional se
hubiese alguna acción se pronuncia
Mientras tanto nuestro trabajo es
mantener el orden público entonces de
ahí fuerzas armadas y policía lo que
hizo fue cumplir con su tarea
constitucional y evitar de cierta manera
que se piense que una decisión de este
tipo por ser la primera vez en el país
que se toma Por eso hay que decir es la
primera y única en la historia
republicana del Ecuador pueda generar
zozobra o pudiera haber generado una
situación de tensión social sino más
bien Esperemos respetuosamente a que los
órganos constitucionales sean los que
tomen el camino y la definición correcta
como pasó en menos de 48 horas jueves
por la noche con una corte
constitucional y posterior a eso en lo
que manda la ley el Consejo Nacional
electoral pues ya hace un anuncio
inicial de elecciones que pronto
arrancan y con eso poco zanja cualquier
duda de la legalidad del proceso y
además me parece que la edad al Ecuador
mucha tranquilidad y mucha estabilidad
que no es y aquí Disculpa queda la
comparación adelantada pero mucho del
inicio hablaban del proceso de castillo
en Perú nada más lejano de esto aquí es
una herramienta que está en la
Constitución y que inmediatamente
provocó un dictamen de la corte y una
convocatoria elecciones en las que ya
mañana entiendo se abre el periodo muy
bien Yo quería hablarle precisamente de
las acusaciones de inconstitucionalidad
la oposición dice que no se justifica la
conmoción interna en el país porque
Creen ustedes que sí hay esa
justificación seguro dos cosas
importantes primero dejar Claro que este
es un artículo de la Constitución de la
República el 148 el presidente que
permite a juicio del presidente en estas
causales activar este mecanismo que él
también le corte el periodo segundo en
junio del 2022 la asamblea nacional en
artículo 130 también tiene esa
atribución y la ejecutaron también
declararon ellos como opción eterna Lo
que pasa es que no alcanzaron los votos
para ejecutarla por qué Sí bueno hay
casi doce páginas del decreto de
disolución de la asamblea donde se
establecen todos los detalles los hechos
y la documentación donde se sustenten
Por qué hay graves crisis político en
función interna pero para decirlo en
palabras sencillas primero de nuevo en
menos de dos años cuatro intentos de
destitución del presidente sin una sola
prueba segundo la mayoría de proyectos
de ley enviados por el presidente de la
República en cumplimiento de su plan no
fueron revisados ni aprobados la mayoría
del chivado de otros ni siquiera han
sido tratados finalmente en cuanto a la
conmoción interna hay una afectación
clara al proceso de seguridad la mayor
crisis que vivió este país en este
momento lastimosamente es de inseguridad
tenemos un problema con el narcotráfico
tenemos un problema con el crimen
organizado internacional con bandas
internacionales que han entrado al país
a lo que estamos combatiendo
frontalmente para que tengas una idea el
promedio de gobierno anteriores
capturaban de 30 a 50 toneladas de droga
por año en menos de dos años llevamos
más de 420 toneladas capturadas Ese es
el combate que se hace Ahora qué pasa
dentro de esa conmoción interna que es
innegable como uno de los conflictos más
graves que tenemos la propia asamblea
por esta crisis política cuando nosotros
ingresamos un proyecto de ley de uso
progresivo de la fuerza necesario para
este combate los señores cogieron y no
solo que no ayudaron sino que eliminaron
por dar un ejemplo concreto y creo que
es fácil de entender el uso de cannes
con la policía que son clave en la lucha
contra el narcotráfico entonces había
con Claridad un choque que no permitía
tranquilidad que no daba paz y que había
casado en el Ecuador una conmoción que
creo que estos días se nota con Claridad
que fue resuelto pero precisamente de
esta crisis quería hablarle yo es uno de
los problemas que más preocupan a la
población del Ecuador no deja sin
embargo la muerte Cruzada desatendida
este problema tan importante y tan
inminente para el país absolutamente No
de hecho la mayoría de ese combate se lo
viene haciendo desde ya varios meses con
mayor intensidad en territorio Como por
ejemplo el uso de Estados de excepción
como suceden esmeraldas donde tenemos ya
casi un mes sin muertes violentas luego
de haber sido la provincia más violenta
estamos entrando en otras provincias con
fuerzas armadas con Policía Nacional
desde el gobierno nacional se está
trabajando muy duro en el refuerzo a la
policía por ejemplo a finales de este
mes entran 8.500 nuevos policías a
formar parte para tener un contexto eso
es un 20% más de la fuerza policial que
ya tenemos han llegado municiones nuevo
equipamiento están por llegar chalecos
nuevos para todas las fuerzas del orden
nuevos vehículos es decir sin duda que
el legislativo es clave porque hay
elementos que pueden aportarse y que son
necesarios uno de ellos por darte un
ejemplo estaba trabajando en una reforma
la ley de garantías jurisdiccionales que
para explicarlo de manera sencilla es un
abuso que hoy se estaba dando se ha
venido dando en el sistema judicial en
herramientas como los Dallas Corpus como
las lecciones de protección como las
medidas cautelares que han servido a
jueces corruptos para liberar a
delincuentes tanto políticos como el
narcotráfico eso ayudaría sin duda
porque es complejo cuando como policía
como gobierno nacional capturamos y los
jueces liberan en la mitad de lo que
capturamos sin embargo no nos detiene Y
definitivamente la muerte Cruzada no es
un elemento que evite que se combate se
mantenga con la misma y más fuerza y ya
para acabar le quiero hacer una última
pregunta me ha comentado que las
informaciones de que el presidente no se
va a presentar a las elecciones son no
son del todo exactas sí que cabe Por
tanto la posibilidad de que el lazo se
vuelva a presentar absolutamente de una
posibilidad entiendo que hay algunos
medios las expresiones del presidente la
semana pasada que estábamos en el medio
de este proceso fueron que no es algo
que está en su mente en ese momento no
eras una prioridad para el presidente
Hace una semana que estábamos en una
grave crisis política sin embargo es
absolutamente legítimo él tomará la
decisión que la decisión incluso
personal y familiar además de política y
entiendo en los próximos horas o días lo
anunciará pues estaremos muy atentos a
esa decisión del presidente lasso a todo
lo que siga ocurriendo le doy las
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
Gracias de ustedes siempre Un gusto de
las órdenes Muchas gracias a nuestros
espectadores les invito a que sigan con
nosotros en francés 24
[Música]